How do I best keep weight on while keeping a time restricted eating within five hours by only diet restriction is no dairy.
Also, if keeping insulin glucose levels low is the reason to do this.
So, understand the keeping insulin glucose levels low is partly the reason to do a time restricted eating, but time restricted eating does a lot of other things.
So, it changes your M-tore pathway and talk to a lot about the M-tore pathway in different things you could look up.
Hey, you could go into the gene course.
The picture that we'll sit right there.
And you can look up the M-tore pathway because that will help you understand this a little bit.
You can try to start the cancer.
But we'll have it a smoothie increase my glucose to rapidly don't go ahead and have a smoothie in the eating window.
And that eating window of five hours is not a magic number.
So, I think this person has already doing an eating window of seven hours.
You could stay at that.
That's fine.
And you could try to do a eating window of shorter, maybe a couple times a week.
That would be fine too.
What you don't want to do is you don't want to be losing weight.
You don't want to be in a state of rapid weight loss.
That means if you're losing two, three pounds a week while you're trying to eat as much as you possibly can in the eating window, then we have to open up that eating window even more.
So, it is the trial and error.
So, just keep track of weight loss.
Maybe I should stick to nut butter and protein powder and don't even use low glycemic fruit.
No, because low glycemic berries and they're the nutritive value of fruits is so important as well.
So, there's, there's just great antioxidant and nutritive and kids are killing products in, you know, your berries.
So, I hate to have you reduce that.
I read when you drink your meals, there's not the same digested process because ideally it starts in the world with chewing.
Well, well, that's, there's, there's some truths to that when you chew, you start to release hydrochloric acid and you're stomach, but when you swallow something, you're going to release hydrochloric acid too.
So, really, it's the better explanation of that is that you're better off not chewing if you're not going to put something in your stomach.
Well, what would you do that when you're chewing gum?
So, I'm not a big fan of chewing gum because if you're chewing gum, it's basically telling your stomach to release hydrochloric acid and then nothing is coming down there unless you're swallowing your gum, which I don't recommend either.
But if you just drink your meal, you're still going to release hydrochloric acid because as soon as something goes in your stomach, you're going to release hydrochloric acid too.
But the act of chewing will help will cause the release of, of talented you're by your salivary glands and it will cause the release of hydrochloric acid in your stomach.
So, not a good idea to be chewing gum, at least on a regular basis.
Also, I have read too much protein can be a bad thing, is there a guideline for that?
Well, too much protein can be a bad thing for certain people with certain types of cancer.
This person, that's not an issue, so you don't have to worry about that.